so you just want to make friends you
don't have an effort hey there i'm aria
and i love making new friends and
apparently one of linkedin slogans is
relationships matter so I figured why
not look into the validity of that claim
by trying to build a genuine connection
with someone within seven days and
hopefully make a new friend along the
way would that be swell to gain some
insight i chat with LinkedIn expert
Viveka von Rosen a real friend I do
believe you can find a friend in seven
days or less everything we do on
LinkedIn is so that we can have those
h2h those human to human relationships
to start
Viveca helps me remodel my profile we
want it so that when after reading your
profile that they almost feel like they
know you photos video you have the
opportunity to upload media taking
vivica's advice I take a set of new
photos for my page you want to create
your LinkedIn profile and you want to
create your engagement on LinkedIn and
you want to create your content on
LinkedIn to reflect your very very best
self the best part of who you are and
then the other thing is recommendations
seeking recommendations I reach out to
people I feel know me best and finally
to add extra certifications to my
profile I hire someone off of Craigslist
to teach me a course I developed myself
when the slideshow rolls just roll with
it I'll now explain a little bit about
should I say that or should I role in
football certainly if you've gone to
school or you've gotten certifications
that are necessary in your industry by
all means add them you've got a friend
in me yeah you've got a friend in me
okay so it's been a few days I've
rebuilt my profile my network has grown
a bit so I think we're ready to get
started so I'm gonna reach out to a few
people that seem interesting to me and
I'm gonna give myself five days to build
some sort of a friendship with them
before asking them to hang out with me
on the fifth day and we'll see what
happens I start sending out requests to
people with mutual connections who share
similar interests
with me this guy works in sushi i love
sushi fantastic i receive a steady
stream of accepted requests throughout
the day although many of them don't
respond to my first message however i do
receive replies from kenny a retired
athlete and nico a former coworker of a
mutual friend tuesday brings more of the
same with accepted requests that leave
me unread we have a food truck in here
today but all i could think about is why
why haven't these people responded to me
on the plus side candy and nico
continued to reply and i also receive a
response from james an actor who like me
went to high school in thailand
so so far kenny is definitely top of the
class he always responds to me the poor
guy probably thinks I'm crazy I keep
asking him questions he keeps responding
he never asks me a question hopefully
eventually he'll ask me a question I
think it will be a victory when Kenny
finally asks me a question but then on
Wednesday tragedy strikes Kenny has left
me on red it's not a good thing this is
the first time Kenny has left me on red
okay crazy however soon after another
twist develops Nico has actually asked
me to hang out nico wrote back to me he
wants to hang out what did you say he
said you know we should we should grab a
drink and chat yeah yeah I know I never
like yeah I'm 20 down when are you free
okay I'm walking home right now I'm
hoping that when I get home I'm gonna
open up my LinkedIn I'll have a message
waiting for me from Nico I won't lie I'm
a little nervous
Nikko didn't respond Nikko is online
right now and he hasn't responded
Kenny chose to ignore me so I will not
go crawling back to Kenny - Kenny yeah I
agree
then one response is from James though
and so maybe maybe James's is the one
but on the penultimate day of my
challenge things take a further turn for
the worse and this is the first time
I've opened up LinkedIn since I started
this without getting a single
notification not good because I don't
that asked me to hang up he has
responded since I asked him when James
is cool Kenny forget Kenny but later
that day
James replies to me once again so going
into my final day I decide that with our
unique Thailand connection I'll see if
James wants to hang out it's my last day
and so today I'm last trips to hang out
with me yet how do you think I should
write the message don't try right so I
send James a message asking him to hang
out and then it becomes a waiting game
it's 11:26 a.m. no response
the time is 353 p.m. no response what
did you ask him we should hang out
sometime are you free this weekend is
that not good Gary I think he's an
elegant wrench I think this is gonna end
with you making a picnic basket and
getting stood up and eating a whole bag
if by yourself on the end of Echo Park
Lake hey you okay guy you you don't need
more France as I arrived home defeated I
open up my LinkedIn to one unread
message he goes nothin okay so what did
we learn
can you use Lincoln to find a friend
honestly I don't think so for the most
part what's up its James
it's James what made you decide just to
hang out with a guy you met on LinkedIn
less than a week ago it was definitely
mainly the Thailand similarity I grew up
in Thailand and he also has some time
spent in Thailand and so I feel like
that was already a unique connection and
you also didn't seem like a cat Fisher
regardless of Lincoln or not I think
what I learned is that you can't really
force a friendship it has to come about
organically and then they go see you
yeah we just lucked out that James and I
had a lot in common and we got even
luckier that when we met in person he
was just as cool I mean for all we know
he they could have turned out to be
deranged you never know you never know
[Music]
there's not five slides of this right oh
my dog this is gonna take forever
Kenny [ __ ] off and die